here are the best viral products i
tested in 2021.
let's start with brows the huda beauty
bomb brows micro shade brow pencil has
this incredibly thin point that makes it
so easy to make hair like strokes it is
a little fragile so be careful with how
much pressure you're using but i love
this pencil if you struggle with using
pencils to fill in your brows i highly
recommend this mad love brow stamp kit
you apply one of the stencils to your
brow and stamp the brow color onto fill
it makes doing your brows so fast and
easy and you don't have to worry about
having two different brow shapes now my
favorite brow setting products everyone
went nuts for the abh brow freeze and so
did i it gives your brows that fluffy
laminated look and keeps the hair locked
in place all day but i recently tried
the elf brow lift and i swear it works
exactly the same it also came out with
this special applicator that really lets
you press those hairs down moving on to
complexion products the fenty beauty
ease drop blurring skin tint is so
natural and beautiful on the skin the
coverage is minimal but very buildable
the l'oreal true match nude hyaluronic
tinted serum is another great option it
evens out the skin and gives you a very
glowy hydrated finish plus you get the
added benefits of hyaluronic acid
the pseudolabs freckles kit is
definitely the best product i've ever
used for creating faux freckles you use
the freckle liquid which has this little
round brush in it and this little
toothpick looking thing to flick the
liquid onto your face and it gives you
these very natural looking freckles this
givenchy prisma libre loose powder is a
huge splurge item that actually lived up
to the hype the colors all blend into
one translucent shade that really
brightens up the under eyes and sets the
face without leaving you feeling dry it
makes the skin look so smooth next my
favorite makeup product blush i tried so
many different kinds this year i think
my favorite was definitely the melt
cosmetics cream blush light this formula
is pigmented and blended like a dream it
layered over powder really really nicely
the m cosmetics so soft blush is also a
cream blush but in a stick form this one
is very user friendly because it is so
soft and easy to blend out you don't
have to worry about overdoing it the
made by mitchell blursh liquid blusher
is probably the best liquid blush
formula i've ever tried i applied this
over my already set foundation and it's
still blended out so well without
removing any product underneath and the
pigment is so intense
now onto bronzer just like the blush m
cosmetics so soft multi face play is
creamy and easy to use the shade i got
was more of a contour color for me but
there are some warmer shades for
bronzing the elf putty bronzer is
another amazing bronzer and an
affordable one the blendability of this
bronzer is unreal it has this really
interesting formula that goes from a
cream to more of a powder finish it's so
easy to work with
next we have some really interesting eye
products these chameleon flakes from
kyma cosmetics are like little shavings
of pigment that shift color they
definitely have a bit of a learning
curve but once you get it they look
amazing on the eyes this product is
technically a multi-use product but i'm
putting it here this is the janessa
myrick's beauty color fix eye cheek and
lip cream pigment the pigment in these
is no joke a little goes such a long way
and the fact that you can use them as so
many different things under eye
corrector blush eyeliner lipstick
eyeshadow is definitely a plus
and finally a few of the best lip
products i tried if you want that full
coverage transfer proof lip definitely
check out the nyx lip lingerie xxl matte
liquid lipsticks one thin layer is all
you need and once they dry down they're
not moving the milani color fetish matte
lipstick is also very pigmented and
wears really nicely these aren't as
matte as you would think and they still
have that comfortable slip that you'd
get from a regular lipstick
[Music]